all science starts with certain
hypotheses and mine is geometry is
fundamental and actually my favorite
saying is one of Galileo's he that
attempts natural philosophy without
geometry is lost
and my belief is that it is actually
geometrical relationships and they can
be Illustrated in the first place I
think with particles in space you can do
an incredible amount with particles in
space where you have separations between
the particles and some separations are
greater than others but the ratio is
well defined it's a pure number but if
you think about looking at the sky at
Orion the constellation of Iran it has a
certain size relative to the total area
of the sky so I think the Bedrock of
physics should just be the ratios of the
sides or the angles